the henderson art festival on water  street returned this mother's day  weekend it was clearly a hit thousands  attended that free two-day event it  featured more than 60 diverse artists  along with crafts fashion home decor and  artisans festival goers also enjoyed  chalk art glass blowing and a special  gallery showcase at city lights art  gallery  i just just really enjoy looking at  everything i mean it's just all  fantastic a lot of good artists come out  here and they display all their art as  well and you like the jewelry don't you  caimans okay the jewelry is here it's  all homemade i like all this stuff you  like the hockey team  painting lessons were also available  rather pretty cool